well i think that the community and the
the loving and the and the care that you
can get from religion are very good
things of course and if only there were
more purely secular groups that provided
not only the good works but also the
community I think that would be a good
thing I've been talking with various
people about the need to provide that
structure in secular organizations and I
think it's possible and I think we
should work at it because you're
absolutely right people sometimes when
there's nobody around to love you and
take care of you it's great to have a
group that you can be welcomed into
well I suppose the the simplest answer
is it would be good if there were and
there are already the churches without
dogmas and in fact more and more
churches downplay a Dogma to the point
of evaporation and concentrate on
providing just the sort of a community
of care mutual care and and helping the
world and so I think it's entirely
possible the churches will evolve into
sort of Creed 'less organizations that
do a lot of good work and that would be
wonderful